big news coming out of the Department of
Education specifically the Department of
Education Office for Civil Rights has
found that a high school sports policy
in Connecticut which allows boys to
compete against girls boys who identify
as girls have been allowed to compete
against the girls in girls sports and
guess what happens the boys win they
found that that policy violates Title 9
violates protections for women on the
basis of sex this is a big political
issue that has erupted whether
protections on the basis of sex protect
sex or gender identity the idea that if
you're a boy you can identify as a girl
obviously that would undermine
protections on the basis of sex and
that's the the argument that's been
happening for many months and I guess
yes over a year now I think at this
point I've got to give Madeline Kearns a
co-host credit on this show because it
seems like every time I fill in for Ben
this issue crops up there's some news
that develops so we are joined now by
Madeleine Kearns the William F Buckley
Jr fellow at the National Review
Institute was written extensively on
this case and on this topic
Maddie thank you as always for being
here thanks as always for having me
Maddie can you tell us a little bit
about what this decision means this is a
decision from the Office of Civil Rights
at the Department of Education so this
is different from the the same issue
being debated in the courts what's going
on here what does it mean for the issue
more broadly absolutely so first thing
to know is this is actually quite a
complicated issue because as you know
there's different tracks if you will so
use that metaphor and this track is the
administrative track and what the
executive branch done through the
Department of Education has signaled
that yes indeed this is a violation of
this federal statute as we understand it
now of course if we are to redefine the
meaning of sex that is for Congress or
the Supreme Court to do but the
Department of Education has found that
yes it is denying girls of their
protected rights when you allow boys to
compete in sports and inevitably beat
them in sports and so
big it's a big boost for morale I think
that that this has been decided in this
way but it does it's certainly not the
end of the story and those three tracks
could converge at some point and we
would be keeping our eye on on all of
three of them so we'll just have to
we'll just have to wait and see with
regards to the lawsuit because we've
seen I mean it seems pretty obvious I
think to a lot of people it doesn't seem
as obvious to left-wing lawyers but it
seems obvious to a lot of people that if
you have title nine to protect girls
sports and to make it such that girls
don't need to compete against boys and
almost certainly lose because boys are
physically stronger than girls if you
then let boys compete against the girls
you've completely undermined title 9 so
it seems very clear and it makes sense
for the administration to to come to
this conclusion but of course it's going
to continue to be fought in the courts
does the decision by the Office of Civil
Rights at the Department of Education
affect the way the courts are going to
think about this meaning courts very
often will defer to some of these
executive agencies is that going to play
a role here when the Supreme Court for
instance makes its final decision or are
these tracks really completely separate
I think the answer is not necessarily
so it sort of depends on on the argument
and the defaming of of the of the
justices I mean what what is interesting
is that obviously Obama during the Obama
era we had guidance issued in 2016 which
was joint guidance from the Education
Department and Department of Justice
which many have which which said that it
was fain to have boys who identified his
girls competing against girls and many
then cited that as their excuse for
having various you know bathrooms hem
and all sorts of problems so it does it
does actually crop up in the courts from
time to time but I don't think it's in
any case clear-cut decision that will
have knock-on effect I think it really
it really depends on the are so far they
are pretty set for it and
so there the case of the three
Connecticut girls versus the boy
athletes and the school boards is still
ongoing so we've we're still kind of in
the midst of that so we'll just have to
kind of wait and see you know it seems
like the momentum in the popular culture
is moving in the direction of redefining
sex to not be sex you know to redefining
it such that a boy can say he's a girl
and then he'll be considered a girl by
by the law and by the government and and
yet there does seem to be a pushback I
mean I talked to people and it it seems
like this might be a bridge too far you
know when you're getting to the point
where boys who have boy biology are
beating girls in sports and taking away
their scholarships and taking away their
trophies that that's a place that we
don't want to go you know that they say
that the Supreme Court watches the
election returns and the Supreme Court
reads the newspapers and the Supreme
Court is is making these judgments
probably too much so in recent years
according to the popular culture do you
have any read on on whether anything has
changed so far in this case and in other
cases you know for instance the Harris
Funeral Home case where it's dealing not
with girls sports but with how sex
protections are applied to employment is
is there any news on that or is it
basically the the Trump administration
is is pursuing one angle here and the
Supreme Court has remained more or less
unchanged it's a great question I think
the with regards to the Harris Funeral
Homes case which is looking at this
issue in regards to employment we're
really waiting to see how they'll decide
it really could be anything I think it
could actually be the earliest Monday I
was chatting to somebody today who who's
in the know so I actually think
personally though it's slightly
regrettable that it's the Harris case
that the Supreme Court and not this one
and precisely for the reason that you
just mentioned to do with momentum I
think that this is just so in-your-face
glaringly obvious like hey wait a minute
it's not fair to let teenage boys beat
teenage girls at sports that's the whole
point of title 9 that's the whole point
of having separate sports teams that I
think to the American
it's just source of a new breeder the
Harris Keys is I mean I think it's
no-brainer and I assume you do as well
Michael but it's a bit more complicated
when you get in the weeds and you start
getting distracted by all these
secondary arguments to do with sex
stereotyping and so on and so forth so I
am honestly I'm a little nervous about
Harris I hope that's just my natural
cautious impulse coming through but I'm
I would be a lot more comfortable if it
was this case in front of the Supreme
Court but hey it's not so we'll just
have to wait and see you're proving the
old adage that the difference between a
Scottish optimist and a Scottish
pessimist is that a Scottish pessimist
says things can't get any worse and a
Scottish optimist says oh yes they can
but obviously things might change here
so we're gonna have to bring you back on
when that when that does happen to help
us break it down thank you as always my
de-facto co-host Madeleine Kearns
you can read Maddie at national review
and follow her on Twitter as well Maddie
always appreciate your perspective
thanks Michael it was a pleasure
[Music]
[Music]